implanté dans le parc régional naturel
de la haute vallée de chevreuse hectares
présente le plus grand campus agricoles
du monde créé par audrey bourolleau et
xavier niel patron de free le centre de
formation a lancé en octobre 2021 son
accélérateur de start up après 135
candidature et 25 présélection 11
entreprises ont été choisies un objectif
commun grandir et évoluer ensemble pour
bâtir l'agriculture de demain on a monté
la première marque d' alternative à la
viande sans ingrédient ultra transformé
donc ça veut dire que à base de vrais
ingrédients qu'on pourrait trouver dans
sa cuisine globalement nous ce qu'on
veut faire c'est à partir du moment où
il récolte son produit jusqu'à la
facturation de ce produit on intervient
sur cette chaîne dawn l'accélérateur de
start-up s'articule autour de quatre
domaines l'alimentation l'agriculture
régénératrice lindor farming et la
grille tech qui fait référence à la
robotisation et l'intelligence
artificielle le kobo tout il aussi la
collaboration entre l'homme et la
machine le but c'est d'avoir de la
technologie embarquée qui soit très
sophistiqué mais que l' usage soit
extrêmement simple et donc on a cherché
à faire de cet outil une plateforme
vraiment polyvalente pour que la
personne gagne un maximum de temps dans
le travail et qu'elle puisse l'utiliser
à beaucoup d' usage différent donc du
semis à la plantation au désherbage à la
récolte les onze start-up vont
bénéficier du double réseau hec paris et
hectares soit 30 mentor et 500 experts
elles vont également pouvoir profiter
d'un espace de travail de 2000 m² ainsi
que de 50 ha d'expérimentation je trouve
qu'ils ont un réseau non seulement de
mentors qui peuvent nous accompagner
nous aider à dire passer à l'échelle et
atteindre ses 2500 de pointer à la fin
de l'année le partage d'un réseau mais
aussi des mêmes valeurs autour de
l'environnement et le souhait d'une
agriculture plus durable c'est génial
parce que ha bien rassembler des gens
avec des compétences extrêmement fortes
dans le domaine de l'agroalimentaire
les mette autour de la table pour
partager une vision commune de
l'agriculture durable l'accélérateur a
pour objectif final de permettre le
développement de 80 start up en deux ans
dans le secteur agricole